Butch Cassidy and the Sundance Kid was
directed by George Roy hill and stars
Paul Newman and Robert Redford welcome
back to the classic movie review series
I've been doing all year reviews and
movies released before 1970 because
there's not enough of that on YouTube
and today we're gonna talk about one
that's a bonafide classic but it wasn't
quite that way when it first came out in
fact a lot of critics didn't really get
this movie but before I get any farther
in the review I want to say a personal
thank you to the sponsor for this video
and that is bomb fell they are a
personal styling service for men
dedicated to helping you find clothing
that you would like to wear and I am
actually wearing a piece of clothing
from them and I also thought it was a
perfect thing to wear in a review of a
movie that is kind of a Western sort of
a Western not really a Western but it's
it's a Western this film had many
critics upon its release Roger Ebert
didn't particularly like it very much he
gave it two and a half out of four stars
and I read his review and I can kind of
understand where he was coming from but
I liked this film quite a bit and I
always have and a lot of it really is
due to the incredible chemistry on
display between Robert Redford and Paul
Newman who made another film together
with the very same director called the
sting also an excellent film I might
like that one even more William
Goldman's script is subversive it's very
funny it's very different from films of
its kind and he later went on to write
such films as Marathon Man all the
President's Men The Princess Bride he's
an extremely talented writer one of the
best scenes in the film and it's largely
because of that excellent dialogue is
Butch and Sundance arguing about whether
or not they'll jump off a cliff or not
all right I'll jump first
nope then you jump first so I said
what's the matter with you
I can't swim
[Applause]
so in case you don't know what the film
is about it is based off of a true story
about two guys who were robbing trains
with a gang eventually they have to go
to Bolivia because they get caught in
America and they try to flee and we
follow them and a woman named Etta
played by Catherine Ross who they both
seem to be in love with as they go on
various misadventures watching the film
again in 2018 which I just did last
night I haven't seen it for a very long
time the film feels almost modern in its
execution the opening five to six
minutes feels like a movie that could
have come out a few years ago it's just
you know technology stuff where you can
kind of tell it was shot in the 60s but
it feels like a very current film in its
execution which is a major compliment
because even great films from the old
days the golden era of Hollywood in the
30s 40s and then films like Hitchcock's
movies in the 60s the way people talk
the way people dressed the way the film
looks you can just tell it's an older
film and with Butch Cassidy and the
Sundance Kid except for some overused
sound effects towards the end the film
feels like it could have come out in
theaters this year and that's a
remarkable achievement but it is
understandable why some critics didn't
love the film at first or why Ebert
thought the film was disappointing
because it does feel challenging this is
not a conventional Western by any means
it's one of the reasons I really like it
but for some that can be hard to deal
with there's also some pacing issues in
the film there's a scene involving
raindrops keep falling on my head the
song that I primarily associate with
spider-man 2 but it doesn't necessarily
feel like it fits in also spoilers if
you've never seen Butch Cassidy and the
Sundance Kid
Katherine Ross's exit from the film
feels very abrupt and almost unnatural
there's a montage sequence in the film
that uses old style photographs to tell
a story that feels like it glosses over
a very integral part and Butch and
Sundance is life and you can understand
why someone would look at this film and
say well that didn't really work for me
or that's maybe not quite a classic but
it's really good I have a few issues
with it and I can understand how anyone
might not end
the film and I ready Bert's review and
some of the other earlier reviews that
didn't particularly appreciate the film
and some of them just felt that the
violence towards the end was a little
too much and cut news for those critics
if you think that's to violence you're
not gonna like any movies from the 80s
or the 90s or today trust me because
that's like nothing compared to today
but I like understanding various
viewpoints different viewpoints I like
reading critics who don't necessarily
feel the same way that I do because a
lot of the times you can understand why
they feel that way but in the case of
this film it's just so well executed and
I just have to disagree I think it's
fantastic
one of my favorite sequences in the film
is actually one of the births least
favorite sequences and that was when
they're fleeing from these guys on
horseback that seemed to be following
them everywhere hill set up so many
shots that featured Newman and Redford
in the foreground and these men on
horseback miles away and they're all in
frame and it's gorgeous
it's extremely suspenseful in the
repeated line who are these guys got
really funny after a while because again
William Goldman's script is just
immaculate and it's timing and these two
actors were on fire and there's a moment
in the film that actually made me say
WOW out loud and it's nothing but an
explosion and in 2018 we've seen a lot
of explosions and movies but there's an
explosion of a train car that has two
men that get hit by the debris and it
just it looks incredibly dangerous it
looks like they could have been killed
and it was incredibly well framed and
executed well that ought to do it
so it's interesting to go back and read
some of those early reviews from critics
who at the time felt perhaps the
production values were too high or they
exceeded the plots or they overshadow
the actors or their charm because today
I look at all of this in camera action
this beautiful cinematography of real
countrysides where these two a-list
stars are singing against a mountaintop
and I think to myself they don't do it
like that anymore and that's one of the
things that's so beautiful about Butch
Cassidy and the Sundance Kid it's a
hilarious film that has some surprising
dark moments and if you've never had a
chance to see it I do highly recommend
checking it out but it does have some
flaws I don't necessarily consider this
to be a film perhaps as good as some of
the others I've reviewed this year in
this series but it's a damn good one I'm
gonna give Butch Cassidy and the
Sundance Kid and a - so like I said at
the beginning of the video I want to
give a big THANK YOU to bomb fell for
sponsoring this video they are personal
stylists for men they will email you
ideas for clothing that you'd like to
have you contact them you tell them your
sizes and you get your own personal
stylist who emails you with a preview of
their selections after which you'll have
48 hours to make any changes or even
cancel altogether you're in total
control they'll send you the clothes
you'll have seven days to decide and you
only pay for what you want to keep you
can send the rest back with free
shipping both ways you can receive
clothes every one two or three months
and you can pause or cancel the
subscription at any time it ships
straight to your door there's no need to
spend hours shopping at a store so
checkout bomb felt calm slash Chris for
$25 off your first purchase that's be
OMB f e ll my experience with the
stylist was very good they were prompt
she was very kind through the emails and
she picked things that I actually liked
and the clothing genuinely does feel
really nice I wore it all day today so
thank you very much - bomb fell please
do visit bomb fell comm / Chris and you
will get $25 off your first purchase
thank you guys so much as always for
watching thank you to Bob Bell for
sponsoring this video
I look forward to more of these classic
reviews I'm going to be doing one a
month for the rest of the year I'm
trying to have a nice varying selection
of classics
films that I just really like like this
one and of course last month's was
planned 9 from outer space which is
definitely an interesting experience
[Music]
thank you so much guys as always for
watching and if you liked this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]